the man to my right he's been here a
couple of times last time he's with j.b
smoove on I was out of town so I'm
thrilled that I'm here when he's back
here for USA Network's shooter which is
back for a second season Tuesdays at
10:00 Eastern Time good to see you Omar
Epps
Brooklyn in the house whooping and
Cowboys now that's now how does that
happen
I know we've discussed this before but I
think it needs to be revisited every
time how does somebody in Brooklyn New
York wind up a Cowboys fan when I was a
kid Tony Dorsett was my favorite player
okay in the league and he was a cowboy
yes
so probably had he been on any other
team I would have been a fan of that so
if he was a jet you'd be a jet fan
that's a hard ah you know what did you
hear each other hard when he just pulled
up stakes where I come from the Richard
projects he is the death i watch so do i
they were a terrible sort of a terrible
I mean you had Klecko Gaston on the
stock exchange Absalom but she had
Richard play Richard Todd came from
Alabama where
name is came from he was supposed to be
better that Richard taught and and they
also he hey whoa he got the Jets to the
1981 AFC championship game with Freeman
McNeal bringing one of my favorite
players
Wesley walking I still have a full
disclosure I still have a Wesley Walker
Jersey that I got in some for summer
camp with my name stitched in the back
so they knew whose it was when I came
back from the laundry for my bunk bunk
like eight or whatever well um but Don
Shula because the game took place in
Miami and free McNeal was coming down
they watered down the turf to make it
like mud and then Tom Prichard Todd
threw I think two or three interceptions
to AJ Dewey not that this left a mark
you know that was old that's a good
something that happened Ryan Leaf
happened these things have noticed yes
yes but no thankfully not to the Jets
but hey no I understand so yes you've
got the Cowboys now you were just in
Oxnard California correct yep what was
that like did you even it then I was
pretty calm okay first time a training
camp drove up and it was great I mean
the whole organization laid it out oh
there you are with Jerry Jones picture
on your facebook you know into the Pro
Football Hall of Fame on Saturn
yes Congrats he's going in all the fame
so what was that like trolling around
great I say for the whole practice some
girls a little fracas make it work you
were there for that too
well yeah I was there for that but I
like that in my team I like that you
know slow you know spiciness going on
even in practice because that's going to
carry over into the season mm-hmm there
was another one after that it's out
right yeah I heard about that one
another one that's supposed to be one of
them including the kid from Baylor who's
trying to become a tight end basketball
player I like it I like when the team's
testy yes we Rico gathers was in the
mixed of this whole thing they got him
off and they let him come back once they
cool down the same way that I treat my
eight my eight year old when he slips
out of manage they gave him a timeout
okay works they gave him a timeout it
works but they look good I mean that
looks good he's so good did you mean did
you meet that it has to mean I did meet
him the thing I love about Dec that you
know I don't think he got credit for
last season was his football acumen
I mean his his audible game was sick I
mean it was it was something special I
thought well I mean even more special
this to throw that he made omar epps of
shooter and USA here in the Rich Eisen
show the throw that he made in Green Bay
right before halftime where he found I
forget who he found in the corner of the
endzone right before half-time usually a
moment where a rookie quarterback would
you know misfire make a mistake you got
to settle for a field goal when you
settle for field goals in Lambeau Field
against Aaron Rodgers usually that's
gonna be a problem right he just fired a
strike for a touchdown right before that
right and that's when I'm like okay this
guy's for real and I'll take Tony Romo's
can see the field again this year yeah
that's when I first thought that there I
make a correlation
please make correlations sir right
before the half in the Super Bowl same
thing happened with Brady they scored
right before to have what Tom Brady did
or Tom Brady these two get what three on
the board or something like that yeah
well I mean I'm just saying it's an
adage you know I see what you get here
we're gonna win this game nope no no no
I'm putting two and two together
you're the reach and you're saying dak
Prescott is Tom Brady I don't know what
eventually I mean
what are you saying I'm saying he has
the potential to be Tom Brady s well you
started that saying they make a
correlation and had I known that was the
correlation I would have said no you may
know that wrong is the host of a show to
snare drug Brady's you know that season
oh look we had dak call into the show
he was great last month and how do you
not fall in love with this guy I mean
he's got his head screwed on straight
right he's calling in to talk about how
he's trying to eradicate cancer which is
obviously always a noble gesture for
anybody but his story but this mommy
lost his mom in the middle of college
and then you know was able to take
advantage of an opportunity and not let
it go to his head and improve in a way
that you always would see some sort of
regression and he just has his head
screwed on straight yeah and the
Metroplex when you got the star on the
side of your helmet you're the
quarterback that things can kind of go a
little bit haywire what about Ezekiel
Elliott though did you
that's the one guy that I think is a
cause for concern someone anyway I'm not
just saying that because it's a Michigan
helmet on my desk but what are you what
are your thoughts on on today
my personal Zeke look he's a kid it
means literally a young he's a young man
it was a kid you knows his first season
in the league he's got it you know that
stuff you just have to live through you
just have to go through you can get guys
to talk to them and hey watch this and
watch that you know you use your common
sense but we both know you know you're
in your 20s could you imagine being your
20s you know starting running back to
the Cowboys you're making all his money
it happens you know he's just got a
mature and go through it and and
hopefully doesn't affect this football
game so what do you think seriously what
do you even guess I'm expecting a season
like what we had left our teen wins when
in the Division I I'm not saying why not
no I'm just I'm not I'm just walking me
through the problem okay keep it this
was the best part about training camp
for me was watching our offensive line
right and I'm thinking two things one
our defensive line is going to get
better because they're going up against
these guys every week so we have no we
got to grow right hopefully get a
secondary my second thought was these
guys move any D line in the league
literally and that's
crazy to me that's their the best in
football on that right of that there is
no doubt oh that there is no doubt the
question is the back end of that Dallas
defense going to improve this year we'll
see and that that that front line needs
to take another step up yeah I'm more
I'm more concerned about our secondary
than the front line the front line these
days on that taco
that kid is huge on that yet I mean
you're talking my language you know I
went to Michigan him and Jordan Lewis
they both you know they both bring some
maize and blue yeah into that spot taco
Charlton will definitely help there's no
doubt about that but the Giants I'd be
concerned about if I were you I like
them a lot totally if you're not always
certainly if you're not gonna have Zeke
week one yes if you don't have Zeke week
one because of what might be happening
and they come in your house on that
Sunday night I I really got a lot of
Giants fans in my family my best that
and you know it is what it is they beat
us twice last year but who went to the
playoffs omar epps the pewter appear in
the Rich Eisen show we want to win the
war I say a lot of the score is I assume
you don't want to talk Knicks in a few
minutes we have left here oh you make
you may pass if you want to pass on I
mean do we early it's the worst man what
happened to Oakley lawyer what has
Oakley this year was a total abomination
it'll be trolling at this point like
they're just that bad
I mean it's so sad man it is said but
Kyrie says he wants to come back come
home why he why well he wants to be his
own man in a wedding get your money do
what you got to do but what what where's
a better fit for Kyrie you're playing
with LeBron James like what exactly
where you going to go where you going to
go as a better fit for you well I guess
the to use kairi's mindset here is
Patrick Peterson to the Cardinals
calling in shortly the mindset is is
let's just say you are signed to TV show
or movie you have been told you have the
lead role mmm okay and you're like this
is going to be my vehicle right omar
epps starring okay and then they say hey
we're bringing in Denzel yes
you know it's Denver sometimes you got
it play your position exactly and in
sports
LeBron's that guy
come on I mean to me I'm just like but
you have to do it for five years but I
get the whole day I get the whole lot
here is one you know he found out that
he might have been a young trading bloc
or LeBron supposed to be coming to LA
you know season that all of that is you
know speculation we don't know what's
going to happen I mean things change on
a dime I'm just like why would you
disrupt the flow now just want the two
chips yeah they take this further you're
going to be in five movies with Denzel
three of them are going to be nominated
for Best Picture and one of them is
going to win but you want to be the gut
but don't you want to be the actors the
reason why that the picture was
nominated I gotta say this analogy is a
bit of a stretch Jackson is great you're
the next Kyrie Irving Omar I get it but
still so headline Omar does not have a
five picture deal with Denzel Washington
I'm tweeting that right now okay let's
talk shooter before uh before you go
gently into that Los Angeles day yep you
can join us loving it loving are you are
you a sharpshooter now yourself I
wouldn't say that I'm a sharpshooter but
yeah I can you have trained for this as
we trained for this Ryan and I both
trained we both hated twelve hundred and
thirty five meter shot oh yeah from the
top of a mountain what in the world is
that likely after you pull that off
it was euphoric it was literally full
cuz we know we trained and we went
through all this tactical stuff and the
guy we were training with buck Doyle
who's like a military legend we drove by
this thing one day we were going to get
some food he was like yeah that's tall
thirty thousand
he told us after like yeah I didn't even
think you guys are gonna get to the
point where we can even take that shot
so you know we start out thousand
fifteen hundred and he seems how like
focus line and I are and we went up
there and hit the shot and you know
fantastic something about it was a great
show shooter on USA with you and Ryan
Philippine omar epps appreciate it what
do you think of Patrick Peterson he's on
the phone line right now right easy
alright now any think of Patrick Peters
in the Arizona
Arden was knowing he's on the phone line
right now oh uh he gets busy he gets
busy but guess what I think we play our
zone
crack it is three or four weeks we we
not being this cast of shooter you mean
though that was that voice yeah cowboy
we hash tag table nation is Patrick on
the line right there you want to put
them up for some night talking smack
Patrick you there all right I got omar
epps here what's up man oh man with that
everything's good that's funny you see
his voice kind of Diplo yeah yeah you're
like we're gonna take the Arizona
Cardinals yeah we got to play you guys
and I'm a Cowboys fan bro yeah I heard I
heard Michelle burger it should come to
them you should come to the game and
watching a person man I'm I got a big
please all right my decision you're
gonna go as guest a Patrick Peterson
that will be a little weird Marty say
might be set me up for failure week
three Monday night o weary Monday night
okay I'll see you at a schedule looks
okay did you gotta wear your jersey
Patrick woo or whatever you want to wear
but not blue fat you're gonna put you
back on ho we'll chat you and I in 60
seconds that's Patrick Peterson the
Arizona Cardinals thanks for coming on
home thanks we appreciate a check out
shooter on USA every single Tuesday at
10:00 Eastern Time back with Patrick
Peterson of the Arizona Cardinals in 67
sir Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy